many fans were very heartbroken when
Netflix decided to cancel daredevil but
today it seems like we may have a bit of
good news for the daredevil fans out
there how's it going everybody it's
Warren and today we have some reports on
Matt Murdock the daredevil himself
according to a report from cosmic book
news a daredevil reboot is on the way
and is going to be a part of the MCU
however there is a catch with this
reboot and I'll break it all down in
this video also don't forget to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 so right now for the next
couple of years due to the contract
Netflix still owns the rights to
daredevil and the defenders however
eventually they will be back in the
hands of Marvel Studios and according to
a report from cosmic book news when
Marvel Studios gets the rights back to
daredevil they are planning a reboot in
the MCU however it will not be the same
actor that played Matt Murdock in the
Netflix series cosmic book news says
their sources told them that the studio
is planning to reboot daredevil but with
different actors now obviously some
people are going to be pretty upset
about this but cosmic book news says
that the TV shows weren't really a part
of the MCU canon however that appears to
be more and more true as we go on
especially since Marvel Studios at San
Diego comic-con announced blade late of
course being played by Mahalo I'll leave
now if you're not aware Mahalo Ally
played cottonmouth and Luke Cage now
many people are starting to question how
martial Ollie could be both in Luke Cage
and blade in the MCU
the obvious answer sadly being that Luke
Cage and the other Netflix shows don't
exist in the MCU and if you look at all
of the TV shows none of them really ever
affected the MCU films even in agents of
shields none of the Avengers in any of
the films even knew that Coulson was
alive yes the films affected agents of
shield but agents of shield never
affected the films but now it seems like
the Netflix shows really weren't ever a
part of the MCU
this is the reason according to cosmic
book news that if they do a reboot of
daredevil and any of the defenders
they'll use different actors to play the
roles but this is not the first report
of a daredevil reboot after spider-man
far from home came out there were
reports saying that daredevil could
appear in spider-man 3 and if you have
seen spider-man far from home this makes
perfect sense
off of the post credit scene for
spider-man fire from home Peter Parker /
spider-man is definitely going to need a
lawyer in spider-man 3 also spider-man
is definitely going to need some help
fighting the mini villains that are most
likely going to be coming for him after
the mid-credits scene for spider-man far
from home in spider-man 3
and if Marvel Studios and Sony stick to
the tradition of releasing a solo
spider-man film every two years
spider-man 3 should come out in 2021 and
by 2021 Marvel Studios will officially
be able to use daredevil in the MCU
because their contract with Netflix
would have expired so it seems like we
could be getting a daredevil reboot with
his debut beam in spider-man 3 followed
by a solo film that would exist in the
MCU so let me know what you think about
this news if these reports turn out to
be true are you excited to see a
daredevil reboot in the MCU even if it's
not with the same actor or would you not
like a reboot if they are not going to
use the same actor be sure to leave your
thoughts in the comments down below and
also don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 and I'll also
still be giving away some Marvel Legends
items as well at 500,000 subscribers as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof